the latest on the alarming new surge in
covet cases the seven day average for
new daily infections is now
about one hundred thousand we haven't
seen that number in the united states
since february it was only about eight
thousand just seven weeks ago
more people are getting coveted shot
about 61 percent of u.s adults
are fully vaccinated but in some
hard-hit areas health officials say too
many people remain unprotected
and this latest wave is overwhelming
some hospitals in the south
or marvia franca is in baton rouge
louisiana omar the situation there
has been serious for the last few weeks
is it getting any better
it's only getting worse vlad covet
hospitalizations are at an all-time high
here in louisiana in fact baton rouge
general their icu is built for about 25
people
they have almost 70 people in the icu
right now the hospital actually had to
convert four different units into coven
wards
just to keep up
[Applause]
inside the icu at baton rouge general
hospital
doctors and nurses are treating more
coveted patients than
ever before almost all of them
unvaccinated
their patients like 61 year old douglas
allen you can't move
you don't have the strength after nearly
a month in a hospital bed
we asked allen if he'd changed his mind
about getting the shot
when you're able medically to get the
vaccine
will you get it on a percentage basis
probably 90 percent yes
i still have that little bit of what the
heck's going on
that kind of doubt is all too common
says hospital chief of critical care and
pulmonary services
dr steven briere how do not feel like
you're just constantly running into a
wall
you see all the misinformation out there
i can understand sometimes
why they make the decisions they do when
you read those lies they're scary to a
lot of people
and those lies are difficult to combat
even for people like nurse jordan miller
i have family members that refuse to get
vaccinated i tell them that we're
building new icus every day and that
we've gone from
24 beds to almost 100 and we have people
in their 20s and 30s
and 40s who are dying and i have
yet to convince some of my family
members
as cases have spiked across the state
rates of vaccination have risen across
louisiana
but more than half the population still
remains unvaccinated
and too many are ending up in one of dr
briere's growing number of coveted icu's
do you feel like you're having to sell
science yeah yeah i i do
sell reason cell logic
whatever it is debunk myths whatever the
person needs to encourage them to get
vaccinated
is what i'll do
the latest wave of cases isn't just
affecting adults the national institute
of health actually says
more than 1400 kids across the country
are right now hospitalized with covet
and that's the highest number of kids
with covet
in the hospital ever recorded tarika
very concerning omar thank you